like to welcome to the program today dr.
Ian Pearson a futurist at future Eisen
who has been doing a lot of work on the
topic of human lifespan life expectancy
to maybe get us into the conversation
dr. Pearson I we've interviewed dr.
Aubrey de Grey a number of times who
also works on this issue although maybe
from a slightly different angle than you
he considers aging sort of a condition
or disease that we can cure is that your
general approach to the topic of life
expectancy and lifespan um not really
I'm familiar with oh pretty great and
easy just some fine work but his
approach is very different from mine III
don't see natural aging as a disease in
the same way as he does I think it's
just natural it's just part of the way
that niche is designed I don't think
it's a malfunction on the other hand I
agree with him that this is something
that can be remedied even though it's
not necessarily a fault of nature it's
it lots of good reasons why nature has
aging it is something that you could
nonetheless resist if you if you wanted
to and a lot of the work that he's doing
will help to push us that direction so
as a futurist I can certainly agree with
a lot of the motives for what he's doing
and some of the techniques that he seems
to be using show some good promise as
well but the biological our technique
for increasing longevity is only one
approach the approach which I favor is
to make really good links between our
brains and the machine world then that
gives you two benefits one benefit is
that we can increase our IQ increase our
sensory capabilities increase our memory
and all that sort of stuff so we can
become better people really but in doing
so we're increasing our brain space
effectively into IT and as our minds
expand into the IT eventually we reach a
point where only a small percentage of
our mind is actually running inside of
our head at that point it doesn't really
matter very much if you die because
you've got a backup of you all your mind
is on the network anyway essentially
it's a backup you can just buy an
Android if any description you like and
you can use
as your body from then on so the way I
would see it this little body is
disposable artifact that nature gives us
but we don't really need it in the far
future we can build far better Androids
and we can live in those so why bother
so a long time before OB degree his
solutions for fixing the biology a long
time before those really come into play
we will have this electronic approach
which really make the biological
approach redundant the IT approach is my
view much better yeah so this this idea
is actually explored in detail in the
new Netflix series altered carbon which
is based on a book I read I must be
twelve or fourteen years ago by Richard
K Morgan but by the same name and so
this is an approach like you're saying
which is not it's it's not the
immortality of Homo sapiens as a
physical being so much as the ability to
take the consciousness of an individual
and move it elsewhere so that digitally
it can sort of live forever
philosophically there's a lot of debate
as to whether that's really human
immortality isn't there you can put all
sorts of different aspects of it I mean
some people think of it as an upload and
I don't think of it that way if you were
taking your mind and making a replica of
it and putting it somewhere else even
that with the philosophical debate you
know have you teleported down to the
planet is it really you or is it just a
copy you can get lost in that sort of a
bit very quickly the way I see it is if
you're gradually adding extra bits of
i.t to your brand via the the cloud or
whatever your mind is still you you just
gradually extending it over a period of
time and if that mine happens to be
mostly resident out in the cloud rather
than in your in your head of course it's
you and the problems and the philosophy
disappear if I guess the one area I
agree with you that it's very easy to
get stuck in sort of hypothetical or
theoretical debates as to whether well
is it really you or is it is it a copy
of you that sort of starts living at the
point that the copy is made or the
consciousness is transferred I think the
I marry way in which it's relevant to me
is if someone goes in so to speak to
have their consciousness transferred on
to some kind of digital device or
digital state the expectation is that
they would experience this as sort of a
you you you go to sleep and you wake up
and now you are existing in the cloud or
in a machine so to speak but it's
possible that the you that goes in sort
of goes to sleep and never wakes up and
then a digital being sort of picks up or
continues your life where you left off
and that seems like a material
difference doesn't it well that's very
different from what I'm describing yes I
don't think that that would actually
replicate you in the mix are we making a
replica of you in that way
yeah it's not the same as gradually
extending your existing mind in real
time into the into the cloud there's a
big difference to making a copy of you
whether it's digital or analog or
quantum you know we can argue that all
day as well but there's a big difference
in a copy of you and actually you I
think that that is essentially the
difference in what I'm describing and
what you just described I wouldn't
anticipate sitting in a seat and having
my mind transfer it onto the cloud my
mind would carry on very much inside my
inside my head inside my organic brain
but I would gradually add extra space to
that mind and gradually that extra space
becomes more of me than what's actually
inside my head so by 2050 2060 9 to 9
percent of my mind would actually be
running on i.t rather than inside my
head so that's what I'm talking about
it's not about doing it download onto a
machine somewhere
it's about gradually using that machine
as part of your brain space and
gradually your mind occupies it so
you're colonizing it rather than
replicating it
FairPoint let's talk a little bit about
the timing you mentioned 2050 2060
you've made a number of different
assertions I don't want to sort of pick
the one that you think best represents
the timing potential that exists here
but in terms of people who are alive now
who do you think is most likely to
already be able to Bennett or
most likely to benefit in the future
from the technologies that you're
describing I think it's fairly safe to
say that anybody that's under 40 today
2018 has a very good chance of having
this electronic form of immortality so
that's a reasonable nice round figure to
cut off those people are still very
likely to be alive
organically around about the time that
this new technology becomes cheap enough
that they'll be able to access it that's
the key thing a few rich and famous
people will get access to this round
about 2050 probably but it'll be very
expensive from very limited by then by
2060 it'll be a lot cheaper ordinary
middle-class people might be able to
afford to buy the technology and get
access and by 2070 it'll be so cheap but
almost anybody in the world will be able
to access this technology so I think
it's fairly safe to say that anybody
under 40 is a very good chance of
accessing this so talk about why 2050
expensive but accessible to the rich
2060 starts to be accessible to middle
class 2070 and the reason I ask is
number one generally humans are just
really bad at making predictions that
are that specific as we know from from
history and number two sort of what
specific technological milestones do you
think are required and will take place
such that that's what we will see
between 2050 and 2070 it's very fair
point a lot of futurists submit some
predictions that haven't come true I
stick very much to just pure technology
predictions and when you do that you can
actually get 85% accuracy
you still get 15% wrong but a bit 85
percent of the time you can get it right
now myself I invented in in 2001 I
invented a technology called active skin
which allows you to put electronics
straight on to the skin's surface and to
link straight through to the nervous
system and we're now seeing prototypes
of that coming and into the market so
we're already starting to see the
beginnings of overactive skin for quite
some time we've had a lot of people with
implants to cure Parkinson's disease and
things like that or a lot of people
retinal implants or implants in their
ears cochlear implants
a lot of those already exists we're
already starting to link IT to our
nervous system which is just an organic
IT that's already with us today and that
technology is progressing really quite
quickly we're also making a lot of
progress in the parallel field of deep
neural network technology for use for
artificial intelligence and that will
replicate some of the same processes for
thinking in IT so we're building the the
IT structures in similar form to what we
think is exists inside the brand at
least philosophically so that it in a
not very far future it'll be much easier
to link we're not linking to something
which is completely alien kind of
architect you were linking to something
which is actually based on very very
many of the same ideas that nature uses
for our real brands so we have a lot of
promise from what's going on an IT plus
what's going on in neuroscience plus
already some existence proofs that these
principles will work that we can expect
that we'll be starting to make brain
extensions of some sort in the 2030s
and by the 2040s we'll be getting pretty
good at those by 2045 there's a very
good chance we should be able to do a
direct brand link which gives you a
fully transparent link both ways between
you and the machine and adding another
five years on to that for FDA approval
takes you to about 2050 before you get
actually be able accesses in the real
world and not 2050 we'll be sort of
prototype technology very expensive very
limited and it will take probably five
or ten years before that comes down in
price to a reasonable level that
ordinary people can start buying it I'm
curious whether if we say let's explore
or let me put in a different way do you
believe that these technological means
are really the only way for the
significant extension of human lifespans
in the sense that when we look at life
expectancy for humans over the last
several hundred years some of the
increases are sort of deceptively high
due to high infant mortality early on so
when you look maybe at like life
expectancy at age five which gets us
past the infant mortality issue we see
that there's actually been a far less
drastic
crease and life expectancy we see maybe
by 2030 that South Korean women who live
a long time might have a life expectancy
at Birth of 86 87 or 88 something like
that but that's not those aren't like
hugely impressive numbers do you believe
that short of the types of technologies
you're talking about that we are very
quickly sort of getting to the upper
limit of what could be achieved merely
by good medicine and a standard of life
and nutrition yeah I mean I've said I'm
not an expert in in medical field but I
do read an awful lot of things about
there's written by doctors and and
medical scientists who think that we
probably are coming towards the limits
of how much you can do using simple
medicine and lifestyle improvement and
so on you know we keep getting told how
we can improve our lifestyles you know
keep fit and healthy and exercise and
all of this sort of stuff
the limit seems to be usually between
120 and 130 when you read those
scientific reports from the field I'm
not an expert so I haven't really got an
opinion on my own in that field but
those are the figures that I see when
I'm reading those medical futurist
papers so hundred and twenty to 130
looks to me to be an upper limit but
when you look at what people like aubrey
de grey are doing they're looking at the
fundamental causes of Aging and seeing
whether there are ways of interrupting
that and resisting those natural
mechanisms i really don't know enough
about that to be able to say whether
that is very realistic or quite
realistic or not at all realistic I
would have to just listen to what over
he's saying and I think well he knows
more about it than I do so I might quote
him what he says but because I don't
really think that biology is the best
route anyway I don't really pay too much
attention to that field and that gets me
to sort of the last thing I'm just
generally curious about since you see
sort of technology is the path rather
than biology do you in addition to doing
the research and work that you do take
like a ton of supplements or something
that you've identified that in the short
term might give you some benefit I know
futurist reycarts vial has this long bag
of supplements he walks around with all
day and is taking about the day do you
do anything like
that no I don't I'm very different from
records well yeah III know he takes a
dozens I think hundreds of pills every
day because he wants to live forever I
mean my view is I'm perfectly happy to
have a perfectly normal life span
it doesn't really worry me if at some
point in 10 15 20 30 years time I'm
going to die I don't really have that
much interest in immortality I track
this as a technological thing as the
futurist I'm very interested in it but
that doesn't mean I'm necessarily
personally interested in doing it myself
I'm perfectly happy to die to disappear
into history
it doesn't really concern me that I
won't be around in a few hundred years
time so I can understand why some people
want immortality but I don't
particularly want it myself absolutely
fascinating work we've been speaking
with dr. Ian Pearson he's a futurist at
future Eisen I really appreciate you
talking to me today it's great pleasure
thank you very much